I am Josh Smith now go be your host for
tonight and we can introduce free
amazing women to this stage any further
ado one stage mary elizabeth winstead go
mental for the canary herself Jordan
you can gasp who's coming up next and
there's some Harley Quinn's in the house
I'm already seeing along here the babes
are prior in the house referred to as
anything else except the babes
yeah babes of praise pointing that - no
worries you can use it in the poster my
checks in the post but it's literally
these girls are high kicking higher than
sporty spice in this guy's you're gonna
be die yang I want to know how badass
are you free ladies in real life
these ladies are incredibly badass I can
I was an adult
yeah we're impressive when we first met
and by the end of this film just proved
to be even more impressive as women and
actors and practically stunt performance
by this point as well stunts honeys you
must have come away of some bruises
we're like really fighting each other in
that I mean we're wearing padding in
certain areas where you get hit but
still we lived in a constant state of
pain and you are actually training for
this you literally just had your baby
right and you were still nursing and you
went into training immediately for this
what was that like it was hard to like
try to juggle it all but I didn't want
to wean him because of my work like
psychologically I thought I can't do
that what you totally could by the way
after you have a child you have a
completely different body and so I kind
of dealt with a little bit of you know
postpartum insecurities about my
different body and this really helped me
feel incredibly strong where it wasn't
really so concerned about how much hits
or but changed or anything like that I
just felt like whoa I feel stronger than
I've ever felt in my life and when you
walk away feeling like [ __ ] I'm a
warrior you know I can do anything I
think that is there some collapse ladies
and gentlemen yes like your body's in
this like you're such amazing role
models for strong powerful women
everywhere and guys how much did you
learn about the power of your own body
image
you really want to be as strong as you
possibly can be and you want the
endurance to be able to keep shooting
because as soon as you get tired that's
when you get injured so you really do
like she said you really do feel so
strong at the end of it it's it's pretty
amazing like your your strength is far
more important and the aesthetic at some
point you're kind of like I don't really
care what I look like right now I just
want to make sure I can keep doing this
because I got another six hours to go
you know I have to say I really
appreciate the fact that like a certain
body image or type or diet was never
ever brought up to me once on the set of
this film no one ever said oh we want
you to look like this in terms of your
body or it was just like be strong you
know learn how to do these movements and
whatever that does to your body great
you know because that's real now you
said to me you could take this you could
take it to eleven without feeling or
worrying a pissing off the guys that is
such an amazing set and experience of
being which you guys said is a very
novel thing for you guys to be on you
have a female director like female
producer right here ding-ding-ding like
how different was it for you guys you
know what you're saying about pissing
off the guys is kind of true I often
find one you feel often alone because
you're one of the only women on set and
then also there's this really weird
competition I don't know if you have
experienced this but often times my male
co-stars like compete with me in this
really strange way not all the time but
I've experienced it in really weird ways
and I'm like dude I'm not your
competition like trust me we're not
going for the same roles okay they made
it such a safe space for us to fail for
us to like do a Glee phases for us to
suck in a scene for us to fall flat on
our faces and I feel incredibly grateful
to have worked in an environment like
that and I hope that's the new normal
you think it's changing guys can you see
it becoming a new normal
we've got a long way to go but for sure
I can see the shift and you walked into
Warner Brothers and you let you pitch
this yourself you told me weather deck
that is like impressive walk me through
what that was like for you and were you
nervous I don't get nervous in when I'm
pitching something like that I kind of
just get really determined for them to
see my point of view and four and a half
years ago when I pitched
it was a crazy idea to say we I really
want to do a female ensemble go gang
action film with an r-rating I just
really wanted Holly to be able to hang
out with all the girls on-screen I
wanted I wanted her to have a girl gang
and I hang out with a girl gang all the
time in real life and then I really see
it in movies and I don't know why and I
think there's a misconception that women
don't like action films or can't handle
in our rating we need like a PG rom-com
which trust me I love them but I also
love all kinds of movies and and I felt
like from the business point of view
there was a gap in the market that's
such an amazing empower thing to do
because we were talking about this in
interviews Wow where you've overcome
confidence issues in your time and
impostor syndrome and all these things
like so it must be amazing moment for
you to feel this sense of pride that
this movie is literally coming out it's
like your baby for so long and then you
like it's like the baby's going off to
college and I'm like god I hope the
world appreciates you I do want other
people to see it and I do want studio
heads to say oh wow that's a great
business proposition let's do that like
this is this is good business what do
you think this has taught you about the
power of girl power playing these roles
now that we're bringing it out it's
hitting home even harder how special it
is and how much it means and how much to
me it really matters you know in my life
and in my career and in the scheme of
movies you know beem beem beem the Spice
Girls gonna be very proud when they see
this that's for sure someone likened us
to the Spice Girls today and I was like
there could be no higher praise I was
amazing yeah I mean that's a big big
compliment yeah but on the top of your
CV hon among amongst you know
oscar-nominated BAFTA nominated she's
got two BAFTA nominations this weekend
guys
yes this girl is the definition of
booked and busy it's really literally
now Jenny you said this amazing comment
to me when we were talking about
representation in film and you said
there was this real amazing thirst and
hunger
to see a new colourful Gotham that we
had not seen before how much do you
think this film would have helped you
growing up
thing yeah you know growing up I had all
these amazing super heroines in my
personal life in my real life you know
my mom my sister my aunt my so many
mentors that I looked up to and I'm like
I didn't get a chance to see you know
women of color on screen playing
superheroes I think there's so many
people now who are like listen we don't
need a seat at the table we'll build our
own damn table and the world is not just
a heterosexual male gaze of a world
right I mean correct yeah I think
there's a lot of a lot other people in
the world and so I think because of the
demand from audiences I think the
industry starting to make more progress
in that I can remember watching films
when I was young and seeing girls that
looked like me and having that inspire
me to become an actor one day you know
and it's it's not right that that was
something that happened for me and maybe
didn't happen for other girls you know
so so I am of course I want to be a part
of films like this but I also want to be
a part of films that are showcasing
people of every kind and every you know
nationality and race and culture because
I think that does matter a lot and I'm
grateful that I'm a part of something
that that's contributing to that every
character in this is going for the
emancipation of some degree how do you
kick every day sexism in the balls like
these characters do every single time
definitely not in the way Harley does
for better or worse probably feel better
it'd be illegal but I do III guess I
took a long hard look at myself a couple
years ago and I thought okay what are
your strengths how can you do something
positive and play to your strengths so I
realized that I am better you know doing
it through my work that's where it comes
across more most authentically and then
kind of waited until my career reached a
point where I could get films greenlit
and when I could get meetings with
certain directors and writers and studio
heads although some people are really
great about doing it on social media or
talking about it or educating people
about it I don't feel like that's my
strength as much as making a film that
has that messaging behind it I feel like
that's where my strength is and that's
how I how I battle it I guess when it
comes to like one-on-one confrontation
that's not my strong point every year I
get older the better I get at saying no
don't talk to me like that know who take
me seriously but that that's kind of
coming with age to be honest I still I
still I still could be better well this
film is coming in like a wrecking ball
where Miley Cyrus like riding it it's
literally like it's so epic and then
finally because I mean you love a
clapping my out Margay you clap him
represent in the house because Harley
Quinn loves a night out as well if you
can take these delightful to classmates
with you on the night out to infernos
girls get your clutches well for Friday
we're here Friday night I think we're
all Friday night yeah are all Friday
night actually yeah so down I don't know
what this is but I'm down a minute I
also would like to embarrass one of my
best friends here right now howdy is
back there whoo he loves a night out and
in photos so uh so we have a fourth
member of the gang right now
Inferno for Wow guys thank you so much
for joining us you are amazing
incredible empowering humans thank god
this film is on our screens changing
voices putting Hollywood in a new
direction you guys are epic let's hear
it for the cast of birds up prayer
[Applause]
[Music]